[Música]
Hola Mi nombre es Ángela Gómez y aquí
comienza ella es hoy el programa
feminista de France 24 según la
Organización Mundial de la Salud el
edadismo es un problema global las
mujeres somos las que sufrimos
mayoritariamente la discriminación por
edad que se traduce en menor acceso al
mercado laboral invisibilización y
presión social sobre nuestro cuerpo
antes de abrir nuestra discusión Vamos a
repasar el informe de Gabriel colchán y
en él como el edadismo afecta a las
mujeres en nuestro continente
discriminar a alguien por su edad es el
y las mujeres son las primeras Víctimas
de estos prejuicios según un estudio de
la Art la asociación americana de
jubilados casi dos de cada tres mujeres
estadounidenses de 50 años o más
enfrentan discriminación con regularidad
al envejecer un hombre es más fácilmente
asociado a alguien carismático o exitoso
mientras que una mujer será más
asociada a su aspecto físico de hecho
esta realidad se refleja directamente en
el ámbito laboral por ejemplo en Chile
las mujeres mayores de 50 años tienen
una tasa de empleo del
34,6% frente al
62,6% para los hombres de la misma edad
las mujeres mayores sufren una
invisibilización son poco representadas
en el cine la publicidad o la moda la
edad de la mujer es un tabú en nuestra
sociedad y ellas muchas veces se
enfrentan a una doble moral
inundan los productos antiedad y todas
las propuestas para borrar los signos
del envejecimiento pero al mismo tiempo
la mujer es juzgada se usa abiertamente
estas técnicas algo que Madonna denunció
en febrero al ser criticada por sus
operaciones de cirugía plástica una vez
más me veo atrapada en el resplandor del
edadismo y la misoginia que impregna el
mundo en que vivimos un mundo que se
niega a celebrar a las mujeres de más de
45 años y siente la necesidad de
castigarlas Si siguen teniendo una
voluntad fuerte son trabajadoras y
aventureras al envejecer la presión sube
el cuerpo de la mujer continúa al mismo
tiempo que son menos representadas en el
espacio público
[Música]
vamos a conversar con Natalia Escobar a
bakiro ella es la coordinadora de
medición del observatorio para la
equidad de las mujeres de la universidad
y Ceci de la fundación www además es
profesora del departamento de estudios
políticos de y Ceci Y cofundadora de la
mesa de economía feminista del Valle del
cauca en Colombia doctora en ciencias
sociales de la facultad latinoamericana
de ciencias sociales flacso y muchas más
cosas pero como son tantos cargos yo le
quiero dar la bienvenida Muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación
Estoy muy contentas de estar aquí con
ustedes pues Natalia empecemos a
conversar Cómo se evidencia el edadismo
en nuestro continente
bueno Esto es un fenómeno que es muy
viejo las personas cuando pasan los 45
años empiezan a tener unas dificultades
enormes para hacer parte del mercado de
trabajo en condiciones equitativas hay
unas ideas específicas sobre las
personas
mayores sobre las personas en edades
avanzadas que por ejemplo no tienen
inspiración no quieren hacer el trabajo
han perdido las ganas han perdido las
facultades también no hay una idea sobre
que las personas viejas pues no sirven
no como si los seres humanos fuéramos
desechables y esto pues además afecta de
manera desproporcionada a las mujeres
sobre las que pesan unos estereotipos
mucho más potentes fuertes y específicos
porque en los hombres se ve un poco más
la idea de que la vejez viene con la
sabiduría en cambio para las mujeres la
vejez viene con la idea de que ya no
sirven para nada porque no tienen las
físicas que tenían en otro momento
asociadas a la belleza y demás bueno y
Porque además se nos está precarizando
desde que somos muy jóvenes el
desequilibrio laboral realmente Natalia
empieza desde que inician nuestras
carreras laborales se profundiza Cuando
somos madres o cuando tenemos que
ejercer como es normal En todo el mundo
de una manera desproporcionada las
labores de Cuidado Entonces porque no
hablamos un poco de esa línea de tiempo
que no nos favorece desde el inicio y
tras del hecho nos castiga cuando
estamos llegando a nuestra edad más
madura
claro Hay que entender que el mercado de
trabajo es un espacio de poder y como
todo espacio de poder pues es hecho para
y por quién lo hace no en este caso son
los hombres los que habitan ese espacio
de poder de manera más representativa y
en mejores condiciones porque sabemos
que el mercado de trabajo trae brechas
salariales de participación de desempleo
es decir las mujeres tienen peores
salarios mayor desempleo menos
participación en el mercado de trabajo
pues por unas asociaciones a la
discriminación eso viene también digamos
muy interceptado con el ciclo de vida
diferenciado que tenemos las mujeres
cierto la vida digamos laboral de los
hombres es muy lineal inicia y
generalmente no tiene interrupciones más
allá de algunas licencias por enfermedad
que suelen ser cortas en cambio las
mujeres inician en el mercado de trabajo
y en un momento de sus vidas pues tienen
el proceso de la reproducción de la vida
no tienen hijos e hijas y en ese momento
pues hay unas interrupciones bien porque
se retiran del mercado de trabajo para
hacerse cargo de esas de esas cargas
familiares o bien porque esa relación
con el mercado de trabajo Se debilita no
es decir se ausentan más empiezan
Digamos como a tener como una doble
jornada Lo que implica que su
productividad se va a ver mucho más
estancada y no tienen Generalmente en a
quien acudir Más allá de a otras mujeres
de la familia cierto entonces Esas otras
mujeres Pues también sufren este este
síndrome del dedadismo y de la exclusión
por hacerse cargo de los trabajos de
cuidado cuando los hijos ya están en
ciertas edades pues lo que pasa es que
las mujeres vuelven y retornan al
mercado de trabajo pero han perdido unos
años de experiencia de trabajo unos años
de esa intensidad donde las carreras de
los hombres Pues
rápidamente pero las carreras de las
mujeres Pues se quedan Digamos como de
alguna manera estancadas o sufren unas
exclusiones mayores Bueno vamos a tratar
de avanzar más rápidamente con las
preguntas porque me quedan varias Y es
que justamente todas esas condiciones
Natalia que usted relata son las que nos
Llevan como mujeres a buscar trabajo aún
en nuestras edades avanzadas pero no los
encontramos y esto esto radica
básicamente en que no logramos una
justicia económica una Independencia
económica porque estamos precarizadas y
relegadas a las tareas del cuidado
Entonces en este círculo vicioso Cuáles
son las consecuencias que esto trae para
la salud y para la dignidad de las
mujeres
bueno para la salud muchísimas
particularmente asociadas a la Salud
Mental cierto lo que vemos es que las
mujeres de mayor edad dicen Pues
definitivamente yo no sirvo para nada Y
entonces vemos mujeres muy desanimadas
cierto en sus posibilidades Pero además
tienen que aceptar unos trabajos muy
precarios pues que tienen unos efectos
particulares sobre las posibilidades de
acceso a salud acceso a los sistemas de
protección social de cada país y eso me
lleva una segunda parte y es el acceso a
las posibilidades de pensión decir las
mujeres al tener unas vidas laborales
mucho más interrumpidas pues no logran
tener las semanas cuando se les cumple
la edad por lo tanto van a tener unas
vejeces mucho más vulnerables mucho más
precarizadas y mucho más inmiscuidas en
la pobreza que los hombres Pues porque
no van a tener una pensión con la cual
vivir Cuando sus capacidades estén
realmente menguadas y sea la etapa de la
vejez en la que necesiten es cuidado de
la sociedad y no cuidar a la sociedad
incluso la Organización Mundial de la
Salud habla de muertes tempranas de las
mujeres asociadas a los edadismos que
existen en el mundo y aquí quisiera
Natalia tocar otro tema que a veces se
frivoliza Pero sigue siendo muy muy
importante y es en lo estético porque no
solamente se no se castiga por nuestra
edad sino por nuestro aspecto físico y
la naturalidad que es envejecer esto
Esto hace que nos penalicen muchísimo
a las mujeres se les penaliza como en
dos etapas de la vida muy particulares
cuando son muy jóvenes porque dicen
bueno que no tienen las capacidades que
todavía no es su momento que tienen que
esperar y eso digamos es una etapa
bastante larga del mercado de trabajo
donde están como como que deberían ser
las asistentes de por ejemplo los
hombres para poder aprender cierto como
una etapa de mentoría que dura mucho
tiempo pero luego en la vejez pues dejan
de ser bellas no para los hombres es
decir dejan de ser deseables dejan de
ser hermosas y en ese en ese punto
Fíjate que parece que fuera banal pero
no lo es porque entonces es una idea de
que las mujeres solamente somos útiles
en la medida en la que somos sexualmente
atractivas no en la en la medida en la
que podemos ser deseadas por ellos no y
cuando dejamos de ser Esas mujeres
deseables Pues nos convertimos en seres
pues que no merecen
pertenecer a los ciclos de producción
que es como la etapa o el lugar del
mundo que tiene más poder y de donde
nosotros podemos sacar Pues los recursos
para la sobrevivencia entonces este
efecto de eres vieja ya no eres deseable
Ya no eres bonita entonces tiene digamos
unos efectos muy específicos y empiezan
a pedirles a los cuerpos de las mujeres
que se comporten de cierta manera no
debes ya eres una mujer mayor tu pelo
tiene que ser de esta forma tu piel
debería verse así entonces hay una
presión también muy grande que empieza a
tener unos efectos sobre las mujeres y
es que las mujeres incluso dejan de
salir a la calle dejan de tomarse fotos
hay un efecto por ejemplo sobre las
madres y es que con el tiempo dejan de
aparecer en las fotos familiares porque
empiezan a sentirse demasiado feas y
sienten que no deberían salir en las
fotos Entonces tenemos muchas fotos de
mujeres por ejemplo la juventud y muy
pocas fotos de las mujeres en edades
mayores porque ellas mismas claro
empiezan a interiorizar un discurso que
es muy nocivo y que por supuesto Tiene
efectos sobre el mercado de trabajo y
sobre la dignidad en la vejez
es absolutamente descorazonador tener
que escuchar estas cosas todavía en el
año 2023 Natalia ya nos queda menos de
un minuto de programa y por eso no
quiero detenerme mucho ahí Porque
podríamos hablar también de cómo se nos
penaliza Cuando hacemos uso de la
estética para no vernos también viejas y
seguirnos Ajustando esos cánones de
belleza que son absurdos pero lo que le
quiero preguntar para de su cierre es si
la cosa de alguna manera está cambiando
porque efectivamente las mujeres se
rebelan contra estas tendencias y esto
se puede traducir en que se ven cada vez
menos maternidades y cada vez menos
disposición al matrimonio
Definitivamente hay unos cambios
demográficos en los que las mujeres
vienen trabajando
alrededor de esos estereotipos pero no
los tenemos que pensar también Digamos
si socialmente eso es lo que queremos no
porque estas son como unas herramientas
que utilizan las mujeres no a veces de
disrupción pero también hay que pensar
Cuáles son los efectos que termina
teniendo también eso sobre la vejez es
decir qué implica con sociedades por
ejemplo que ya tienen unos digamos una
población muy envejecida no y mujeres
que no quieren tener hijos Entonces cómo
vamos también a continuar digamos una
sociedad donde lo el el el la sociedad
entera nos dice no tengas hijos cierto o
no tengas familia o no hagas lazos
Porque esos lazos te van a dañar y con
las consecuencias que eso acarrea Exacto
tenemos que reivindicar también el el
lugar del trabajo de cuidados para que
los hombres se hagan cargo del estado se
haga cargo el mercado de trabajo se haga
cargo de los cuidados y eso no implica
unas penalizaciones desproporcionadas
para las mujeres Pues es que si nosotras
no pueden sobrevivir Natalia Muchísimas
gracias a usted nos da definitivamente
mucho para pensar mucho para reflexionar
y sobre todo mucho para trabajar Que
tengan un feliz día Muchas gracias que
estén muy bien ha sido un placer estar
con ustedes una vez más en ellas hoy nos
vemos Próximamente también en toda la
programación de France 24 gracias a
ustedes
[Música]